j'avais encore une petite question alors
sur le côté financier quand une
mais là on est plus là pour parler sport
que par les finances malgré tout quand
un tour de France comme ça passe à 50
ans en Yvelines est-ce que il y a un
financement quelconque de
l'agglomération comme une ville étape ce
soit le pour le départ ou l'arrivée ça
effectivement là c'est le Conseil
Général qui prend en charge le départ à
Versailles mais par contre les équipes
de l'agglomération comme des communes
sont mobilisées pour l'organisation de
ce passage pour que la sécuriser soit
parfaite donc agent municipaux police
municipale et les coûts bien sûr et les
coûts comme celui de la signalétique à
mettre en place puisqu'on va fermer les
routes à un moment donné donc il y a une
signalétique à mettre en place pour
faire des déviations ou éviter que les
gens se trouvent coincés sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines avec la
préfecture Conseil Général pour que tout
soit bien et les communes et l'agglo
tout le monde assez ensemble vous savez
c'est vraiment
une question d'équipe donc on prend
effectivement
en charge toutes ces aspects là
Xavier je parlais de ton rôle un petit
peu tout à l'heure puisque le 21 juillet
tu vas parcourir les 133 km mais un
petit peu avant le peloton des
professionnels explique-nous un petit
peu quelle va être le principe de cette
étape en fait il y a 8 il y a des
juniors qui sont sélectionnés dans le
département et donc bah on fait le
Versailles Champs-Élysées le verset des
Champs-Élysées une heure avant le coton
en fait et comment vous avez été
sélectionné
c'est très peu c'est c'est vraiment une
chance en fin de compte un petit peu non
moi c'est un peu de la chance et aussi
au niveau ils vont pas prendre les plus
faibles c'est grâce à tes résultats sur
la saison que tu as pu être un peu
sélectionné c'est ça ouais voilà c'est à
cause de ça mais c'est un choix que tu
as fait de devoir participer ou c'est
vraiment une vraie sélection c'est une
détection quoi c'est toi
et après une sélection et c'est un rêve
pour toi justement de te dire je vais
pas je vais parcourir ces pavés juste
avant le peloton il va y avoir déjà
beaucoup de monde j'imagine près des sur
les Champs-Élysées c'est un peu un rêve
comme n'importe quel cycliste dans sa
vie faire la dernière étape c'est plus
la dernière quoi c'est vraiment tu vas
t'y préparer un petit peu
de façon spécifique ou tu as déjà le
niveau physique avec tous les
entraînements dans la semaine c'est à
cause d'entraînement toute l'année je
suis déjà au niveau puis je ferai un peu
plus quand même quand ça approchera un
classement non il y aura pas de
classement c'est vraiment une course
dans l'amitié c'est pas une vraie
quand même l'esprit de compétition quand
même non c'est avant tout
une amitié quoi pour le pour le plaisir
ça fait deux ans deux ans ça fait pas
beau quand même 2 ans
en fonction des catégories c'est déjà
niveau alors pour faire 133 km
vous parliez tout à l'heure Catherine de
l'aspect financier justement quand tu as
une étape passe dans des est-ce que il y
a des retombées économiques au niveau
touristique quand le Tour de France
passe à 50 ans en Yvelines je pense aux
hôtels notamment bien sûr pour toute une
région le Tour de France est un plus
pour les hôteliers pour les
restaurateurs il y a effectivement une
foule de gens qui consomment donc c'est
forcément un plus alors pour le Tour de
France pour nous c'est moins important
que par exemple pour Paris Brest Paris
ou là on voit effectivement les
hôteliers font en une semaine ils font
un mois de travail donc ils sont très
intéressés pour le Tour de France pour
une ville pour un passage dans le Tour
de France c'est mon impactant pour une
ville départ ou arrivée effectivement
c'est vraiment intéressant au niveau
économique d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
toutes les villes
essayent d'être vu le départ ou étape à
chaque fois l'agglomération
dans le tour de 86 une épreuve
contrairement à Paris qui a eu lieu à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
justement par rapport à ces hôtels tout
à fait souvent même bien réservé il y a
à côté des campings puisque les
itinéants qui suivent tout le tour de
France et 3 semaines de course bah
selonge comme cela et dans le
département il y en a un du côté de
Versailles c'est le camping Utopia d'où
partira évidemment cette 21e étape et
les réservations se bousculent déjà pour
cette période je vous propose d'écouter
le directeur du camping Axel Penin au
micro de Patrick Jacques delixmude
ce sont beaucoup des touristes
itinérants camping caristes
quel que soit la nationalité donc
certains de français beaucoup
d'Européens Europe du Nord des
Scandinaves beaucoup leur nationalité
des bamboucous du vainqueur du Tour de
France on a souvent des pics de danois
par exemple quand il y avait quand il y
en Auris avait gagné il y a quelques
années depuis trois quatre mois déjà
depuis mars avril on a on a
effectivement beaucoup de monde en
général sur cette période et ça c'est un
petit peu pointu encore sur le sur le
week-end de l'arrivée du Tour de France
alors vous préparez évidemment le Tour
de France le passage du Tour de France
depuis plusieurs mois j'imagine mais
pour les téléspectateurs au final le
coup d'envoi c'était il y a quelques
jours un samedi pour la première étape
nous sommes allés leur demander s'il
s'intéressait à 7 centièmes édition
micro-trottoir réalisé par Hassana Yadi
et Jonathan Wilman
de loin avec mon mari c'est à dire que
je
l'ai me résumer chaque étape de temps en
temps voilà occasionnellement non
pourquoi parce que ça ne m'intéresse pas
et en plus ils sont tous dopés et tout
le monde continue à marcher donc c'est
dommage pour eux mais
ce que je pense que les joueurs sont
largement enfin les coureurs sont
largement autant victimes
bien plus même que le public c'est les
premières victimes mais voilà et je suis
pas très très sport parce que je suis
occupé pendant ce temps là voilà je sors
mon mari mais pas moi pourquoi vous ne
suivez pas autre chose à faire à ce
moment-là c'est en plein milieu de
l'après-midi donc je le regarde pas
forcément parce que j'ai pas eu le temps
de suivre ces derniers temps c'est pour
ça parce que ça m'ennuie profondément
voilà mais alors vraiment profondément
j'ai horreur de ça
ça finit bien
Tour de France on entendait dans une des
réponses parler de dopage est-ce que le
les cas de dopage récent nuisent autour
de France et notamment les propos de
Lance Amstrong il y a quelques jours le
problème du dopage ça serait un sujet en
soi aujourd'hui on focalise sur le vélo
alors que c'est un vrai problème de
santé global du sport santé c'est-à-dire
pour ça d'ailleurs avec la fac de
médecine on envisage avec la Fédération
Française de Cyclisme d'avoir une vraie
dimension sport santé sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines après le
problème de la lutte contre le on sait
très bien que il faut y mettre les
moyens vraiment pour l'instant de
toxicologie qui est déjà installé à
l'université à la fac de médecine qui
est près à participer à la lutte
antidopage par exemple ils font
l'analyse des cheveux et on vient de
financer l'acquisition d'acide un
spectre de masse dans lesquels
effectivement on peut à partir de vos
cheveux détecter ce que vous avez pris
pendant les trois derniers mois donc
c'est un moyen de plus pour lutter
contre les tricheurs les tricheurs
envoie d'ailleurs ceux qui se rasent
complètement on peut avoir des doutes
déjà vous rappeler de pantaly par
exemple malheureusement le malheureux
ben effectivement c'est un bon moyen de
lutte contre le dopage la spectrummas
des cheveux Xavier toi qui pratique
couramment le vélo et puis à haut niveau
quand tu dis je fais du vélo quelle est
la réponse de tes copains ou de tes
proches te disant c'est un sport de dopé
bah oui ça revient tout le temps mais
bon après on leur explique et puis c'est
partout le dopage de toute façon c'est
parce que c'est vraiment focalisé sur le
vélo mais sinon c'est il y a du dopage
et on va essayer d'oublier un petit peu
le dopage parce qu'il y a quand même un
tour de France qui qui a bien commencé
et de sport de niveau qu'il faut qu'on
retraite et la ministre des sports ou la
connaissez c'est un médecin et très
ferme sur ces domaines là il le faut de
toute façon pour elle éliminer les
tricheurs de ce tour de français du
sport en général sur ce Tour de France
quelle va être votre favori Robert
casalbert
voilà non mais c'est c'est vrai que tout
le monde pense à Thomas Buckler qui est
effectivement qui a montré dans les
tours pendant comment on pouvait se
battre même si on n'a pas forcément tous
les moyens on peut se battre sur un tour
de France et exister de façon sportive
après effectivement il y a plein de
jeunes qui qui montent et et tant mieux
et de ton côté Xavier j'imagine que
c'est peut-être pas français non non
c'est pas très français moi je
j'aimerais bien que Peter Sayen gagne
autour mais c'est un plus un peu cher
sprinter ça va être plus difficile dans
les côtes puis là il est pas super bien
parti il a fini deuxième d'ailleurs de
cette étape aujourd'hui du côté de
grimpeur sprinter d'accord
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
venu ce soir dans cette dans ce dernier
set huit sport de la saison merci
beaucoup puis bon Tour de France si vous
le suivez